Jenna says then one of my best friends
was born and raised in Jakarta Indonesia
I spent 4 months with her traveling
around Southeast Asia I personally feel
as I witness many events that made me
feel negatively toward Islam especially
the harsh treatment toward women however
despite the fact my friend is a
Christian she defends the Islamic
religion devoutly
how is it possible for people immersed
in the culture to be blind to the evils
of Islam and the necessity of a reform
when you live in a system any system it
is very difficult to say the system
needs reform this is true for all
systems people have an inherent interest
in preserving the systems with which
they grew up the systems in which they
believe and so they are always going to
whitewash those systems it is the
obligation of every moral person to
determine what are the moral precepts in
which they believe and whether those
moral precepts are indeed more valuable
than the systems to which they professor
legions and if you're not willing to
stand up against those systems when
those systems come into conflict with
your principles then you have become a
lackey of the system and that is a deep
problem for anyone in ending system
religious non-religious governmental
political it just that's the truth
across the board